.
YOU CAN'T MAKE IT UP TUCKER
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO SPEEFIVE.
RUSSIAN FORCES NOT LUNCHING
DEADLY ATTACKS AGAINST
POPULATION ZONES, CIVILIAN
POPULATIONS, AS REVENGE AGAINST
THE UNSUCCESSFUL UKRAINIAN
STRIKE THAT DISABLED THE BRIDGE
TO CRIMEA, THAT THIS AS
VLADIMIR PUTIN THREATENS TO GO
NUCLEAR, BIDEN WARNING THAT IT
COULD BE ARMAGEDDON AND THE
WORST CRISIS SINCE THE
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS BEFORE
JETTING OFF TO DELAWARE FOR SOME
REST AND RELAXATION.
WE'LL BRING YOU THE LATEST AND
CHECK IN WITH COLONEL
OLIVER NORTH.
LATER, BOMB SHOW EVIDENCE THAT
COULD RESULT IN CHARGES AGAINST
HUNTER BIDEN BUT THEY'RE MISSING
THE BIG PICTURE.
BUT WE HAVE A VOICE MAIL
ALLEGEDLY LEFT BY HIS FATHER TO
HUNTER AND THAT SHEDS NEW LIGHT
ON HOW HUNTER LIKELY LIGHT ON
THAT GUN APPLICATION.
WE'LL PLAY THE RECORDING AND LET
YOU DECIDE.
ALSO THE ONE AND ONLY
STEPHEN A. SMITH WILL JOIN US ON
HIS TAKE ON JOE BIDEN, THE
KANYE WEST SCANDAL AND SO MUCH
MORE.
APPARENTLY PEOPLE CAN'T BELIEVE
HER FRIENDS.
A LOT OF CHATTER ON THE INTERNET
ABOUT THAT.
FIRST WERE 29 DAYS AWAY FROM
THIS INFLECTION POINT IN OUR
COUNTRY, A TIPPING POINT
ELECTION IF THERE WAS ONE, OUR
MIDTERMS.
REPUBLICANS ARE SURGING OVER THE
COUNTRY IT SEEMS, MOMENTUM HAS
CLEARLY SHIFTED TOWARD
REPUBLICANS.
IN JUST A MOMENT WERE GOING TO
HEAR FROM ARIZONA GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATE CARY LAKE.
WAIT'LL YOU HEAR ABOUT HER
OPPONENT AND ABOUT LEE ZELDIN,
NOW DOWN BY LESS THAN TWO POINTS
TO DEMOCRAT KATHY HOCHUL AND THE
LIBERAL STATE OF NEW YORK.
WE BEGIN IN FLORIDA WITH THE
POWERFUL ADD, NOT ALL ADS NEED
TO BE NEGATIVE, FEATURING THE
STATE'S FIRST LADY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I GET ASKED ALL THE TIME.
WHO IS RON DeSANTIS?
AS A KID WHO GREW UP RIGHT HERE
IN FLORIDA, WORKING HIS TAIL
OFF, PAYING HIS OWN WAY THROUGH
SCHOOL, VOLUNTEERING TO SERVE IN
THE NAVY IN SERVING IN IRAQ.
I'M HE IS THE MAN I PHONE FELL
IN LOVE WITH AND HE'S THE DAD OF
THREE RAMBUNCTIOUS CHILDREN.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHO
RON DeSANTIS REALLY IS, WHEN I
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER, AND I
WAS FACING A BATTLE FOR MY LIFE,
HE WAS THE DATA TO CARE OF MY
CHILDREN WHEN I COULDN'T.
HE WAS THERE TO PICK ME OFF OF
THE GROUND WHEN I LITERALLY
COULD NOT STAND.
HE WAS THERE TO FIGHT FOR ME
WHEN I DIDN'T HAVE THE STRENGTH
TO FIGHT FOR MYSELF.
THAT IS WHO RON DeSANTIS IS.
>> Tucker: THE COUNTRY'S BEEN
BOMBARDED WITH SO MANY NEGATIVE
ADS, IS IT NICE TO GET A BREAK
FROM THAT?
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS IS DONE A
GOOD JOB FOR PEOPLE IN FLORIDA,
LOOK AT HOW HE RESTORED 98% OF
POWER IN FLORIDA AFTER HURRICANE
IAN.
HE WAS RIGHT NOT TO SHUT DOWN
FLORIDA DURING COVID.
IN SCHOOL EDUCATION, KIDS HAD IT
IN FLORIDA IN AUGUST OF 2020.
HE TOOK UNFAIR ATTACKS ABOUT
THAT BUT SHOWED LEADERSHIP.
HE'LL PROBABLY GET REELECTED AS
A RESULT.
HIS DECISION TO SEND ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT PEOPLE TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD TO EXPOSE A LOT OF
LEFT-WING HYPOCRISY.
IN 29 DAYS FROM TODAY, IS USER
CRITICAL.
PENNSYLVANIANS HAVE SAID THE
JOHN FETTERMAN IS NOT EXACTLY
EARNING ANYBODY'S VOTE.
IT'S A STATISTICAL DEAD HEAT IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
IN FACT, THE SOCIALIST CANDIDATE
NEVER HAD A REAL JOB UNTIL HE
WAS 50.
AND THEN WHEN HE GOT ELECTED AS
A PART-TIME MAYOR OF THE TINY
BOROUGH WITH A 2100 PLUS
POPULATION, HE WAS STILL LIVING
OFF MOMMY AND DADDY IS SO
PATHETIC LIFE.
DESPITE THIS, HAVING A PART-TIME
JOB, HE SKIPPED OUT OF MOST OF
THE CITY COUNCIL MEETINGS.
AS LIEUTENANT GOVERNMENT HE ONLY
WORKED FOUR HOURS A DAY.
AND HE HAD NOTHING ON HIS DAILY
SCHEDULE FOR THE THIRD OF ALL
WORKDAYS.
TO MAKE MATTERS WORK, FEDERMAN'S
MASSIVE STROKE THAT HE HAD IN
MAY HAS NOT LEFT HIM SERIOUSLY
DISABLED.
SO FAR HE'S BEEN UNABLE TO
DEBATE.
HE REALLY TAKES QUESTIONS FROM
THE PRESS, NOT MANY HAVE SEEN.
HE RARELY SPEAKS IN PUBLIC FOR
MORE THAN FIVE OR 10 MINUTES.
BUT ON THE RARE OCCASION HE
LEAVES HIS HOME, IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR THAT FEDERMAN IS NOT FIT
TO HOLD OFFICE.
YOU DECIDE.
>> SHOULD JOE BIDEN RUN AGAIN IN
2024?
>> I THINK THAT SHOULD BE A
DECISION MADE BY JOE BIDEN.
>> WE ARTIE KNEW THIS CAN BE A
TIGHT RACE.
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN RUNNING LIKE
THIS IS DOWN FIVE POINTS >> HE
UNDERSTANDS HOW EXTREME IT IS
AND WANTS TO LIE AND MAKE SURE
PEOPLE PRETEND HE DOESN'T HAVE
THE EXACT SAME VIEWS AS DOUG
MAAS TRIANO IS.
>> I WANTED TO CHECK AND SEE HOW
YOU'RE FEELING, HOW YOU DOING?
>> I'M DOING FANTASTIC.
AND IT'S NOT ABOUT KICKING BALLS
IN THE AUTHORITY.
>> Tucker: PRESIDENT JOB IN?
KICKING BALLS IN THE AUTHORITY?
IT'S WORSE WHEN HE'S NOT CHASING
INNOCENT AFRICAN AMERICANS DOWN
THE STREET AND HE WANTS
PENNSYLVANIANS ECONOMY TO EMPTY
AMERICA'S PRISONS, FIRST-DEGREE
MURDERERS, HE ALSO SUPPORTS
LEGALIZATION OF HARD DRUGS LIKE
HEROIN AND FENTANYL FOR IT HE
WANTS TAXPAYERS TO PAY FIRST
SAVE FREE SHOOTING ZONES FOR
HEROIN ADDICTS.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THAT UP.
AND AS A SOCIALIST HE SUPPORTS
OPPRESSIVE TAXES, EXTREME
GOVERNMENT REGULATION -- BUT HE
HASN'T HIS OWN TAXES.
I OFFERED THEM THREE HOURS ON
THE RADIO SHOW AND ONE HOUR AND
THEY SHOWED THE DEFENDANT'S
RADICAL AGENDA BUT GIVEN HIS
COMPREHENSION PROBLEMS OR
WHATEVER, HE WON'T ANSWER OUR
REQUESTS.
WE SENT OUT THE MESSAGE MANY
TIMES GREAT SO WE DECIDED TO
TAKE THINGS UNDER OUR OWN HANDS
AND WE SEND OUR OWN SARA CARTER
TO PENNSYLVANIA TO GIVE HIM AN
ENGRAVED INVITATION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. FEDERMAN.
MR. FEDERMAN.
WILL GIVE YOU GUYS A FULL HOUR
OF PRIME TIME ON FOX NEWS.
MR. FEDERMAN.
SEAN HANNITY HAS INVITED YOU TO
TAKE THE FULL HOUR ON FOX NEWS,
PLUS THREE HOURS OF HIS RADIO
SHOW.
SIR?
ONE FULL HOUR.
YOU'LL HAVE IT ALL.
>> Tucker: THAT'S FOUR HOURS
OF AIR